The White House warning
China against, quote,
growing aggressiveness by its military
after this.
You're looking here on your screen.
This is a near collision
between an American
and a Chinese warships.
And this actually occurred
in the Chinese Strait.
Think about the Taiwan Strait.
I mean, look at how close they are
It won't be long
before somebody gets hurt.
That's the
that's the concern
with these unsafe
and unprofessional intercepts.
They can lead to misunderstandings
they can lead to miscalculations.
This comes as top officials
from the US State Department
and the NSC are in Beijing,
where they had
a, quote, candid and direct discussion
with their Chinese counterparts today
amid these increasing tensions
Will Ripley is OUTFRONT
on the streets, in the skies
and on the sea.
Rising rhetoric and the U.S.
warns real danger
of military confrontation.
A growing list of U.S.
China flare ups
fueling fierce
anti-American sentiment
among the Chinese public.
Chinese state media
adding fuel to the fire,
blasting the airwaves with outrage.
Public perception of the U.S. plummeting.
A recent Chinese poll reveals
more than half of those surveyed
had a very unfavorable
or somewhat unfavorable impression
of the U.S..
Alternately, why, while the U.S.
keeps picking on China,
says this man in Beijing.
It feels like the US is bullying China.
Those are a little edgy.
Another making his views clear,
I don't like the U.S..
All bad things in the world
are caused by the U.S..
U.S.
polls show
many Americans
have similar views about China,
even in polarized Washington.
Countering Beijing has rare
bipartisan support
from the Taiwan
Strait to the South
China Sea to Singapore.
The U.S.
and China seem to be spiraling
closer to conflict.
On Saturday,
a near collision on the Taiwan Strait,
the U.S.
accused a Chinese warship
of cutting off a U.S. Navy destroyer.
The U.S.
says both ships came within 150 yards,
less than 500 feet of each other.
The U.S.
destroyer took emergency measures
to avoid a collision, a close encounter.
U.S.
Defense Secretary Lloyd Austin
called extremely dangerous.
I'm concerned about at some point
having an incident
that could very very quickly spiral
out of control.
Austin speaking at this Asian Defense
Summit in Singapore.
The Pentagon says China rejected
a proposed meeting
with its defense minister, Nishank,
who their only interaction,
this brief handshake.
The U.S.
says they did not have
a substantive exchange.
What a woman
generally had plenty to say
after the near collision.
Blasting U.S.
claims of a peaceful passage
through the Taiwan Strait
with a Canadian warship.
They are not here for peaceful passage,
he says. They are here for provocation.
Tensions are already high,
getting even higher
just days earlier
over the South China Sea.
A mid-air incident caught on camera.
A Chinese jet danger
as they close to a U.S.
reconnaissance plane.
The U.S.
calls this
an unnecessarily aggressive maneuver.
China says it was just
safeguarding its sovereignty,
accusing the U.S.
military plane of deliberately intruding
into China's training area.
The government spokesperson
saying the U.S.
should immediately
stop such dangerous
and provocative actions.
Washington rejects
Beijing's territorial claims over
nearly all the South China Sea,
saying
the United States will continue to fly
sail and operate safely
and responsibly
wherever international law allows.
Tensions rising ever since
a controversial Taiwan trip
by former U.S.
House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi last year
and this year's meeting in California
between House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy
and saying when president of Taiwan.
China also claimed
sovereignty over
the self-governing democracy
its communist
rulers have never controlled.
Launching two rounds of massive
military drills near Taiwan,
only adding to U.S.
concerns
of a potential military miscalculation
with massive consequences
I mean.
Well, it's amazing to see that.
I mean, just to
think about 450 feet apart
and the speed with that way
that those ships were moving,
I mean, you just think about
what could have happened.
The White House I know, says top U.S.
officials brought up this near
collision during their meeting
with Beijing in Beijing today. I'm sorry.
What are the Chinese
officials saying about it?
Publicly, not much other
than calling on the United States
to stop what they call
provocative behavior, Aaron.
But look,
just the fact that there are talks
happening in Beijing
is an encouraging sign,
because for months the U.S.
has been trying to rekindle
high level diplomacy.
Remember, there was a
thaw when
President Biden and President
Xi met in Bali last November,
but then the suspected Chinese spy
balloon on the eve of
you know,
it was supposed to be
a very important diplomatic visit
by the secretary of state to Beijing
that derailed the whole thing.
And basically,
both sides haven't been able
to communicate
at a high level ever since.
So if indeed
now there are these lower
level discussions,
perhaps that could lead
to higher level meetings,
which could try to potentially put
some sort of a pause
in this escalating tension
that really has been going
you know,
whether it's Taiwan,
the South China Sea,
China's deepening partnership
with Russia, There's a lot that the U.S.
and China need to talk about
to avoid a misunderstanding Erin.
All right.
Well, thank you very much from
Taipei tonight.